علينا من المطار سفير النرويج في السودان
اند روستيانسن وهو في طريقه الى اوسلو بعد
عمليه اجلائه من السودان السفير اندرو ما
هي المصاعب التي واجهتكم خلال عمليه
الاجلاء من السودان
طبعا الوضع كان اصعب داخل السودان
وداخل الخرطوم بالنظر الى ان الى قربنا من
مركز العمليات ومن ثم انتقلنا الى مكان
امن حين وصلنا الى موقع اكثر امانا وجب
علينا الانتظار ومن ثم اتى احدهم من اجل
ان يخرجني ومن ثم كنت على متن الرحله
المتوجهه الى مكان بعيد وبعد ذلك
وصلت الى دياري كيف كانت ساعات ما قبل
تقرير مغادره البعثه الدبلوماسيه
النرويجيه ما الذي كان يقلقكم اكثر شيء
اكثر ما اقلقنا هو ما سيحصل في السودان
بعد ذلك طبعا السلامه الشخصيه مهمه ولكنني
كنت قلقا بشاني طاقه مع عملي
وتعرفون حين يغادر الاجانب سوف يكون الشعب
السوداني اكثر تعرضا واكثر او في خطر اكبر
هذا ما يحصل وبالتالي حاولنا قدر الامكان
ان نبقى لاطول فتره ممكنه ولكن بالنظر الى
ظروف محيطه بوضع انا وجب ان اغادر لسلامه
الشخصيه كان قرارا صعبا وشاقا جدا وانا
سوف لن انسى هذه الفتره طوال حياتي
كدبلوماسي ما الذي يعنيه مغادره البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
لبلد ما يشهد اشتباكات كما هو الحال في
السودان
انه اسوا شيء يمكن ان اتخيله انه فظيع
ولكن احيانا يكون ضروريا كل ما بقي من
سفاره لانني تخليت عن سيارتي حين كنت
اغادر هو مجرد علم كان موجودا في السياره
وختم ايضا اذا وجبت المغادره واخذ كل شيء
معنا لئلا يستغل احدهم الوضع ويدخل
السفاره ويستخدم ما فيها لاهداف
سلبيه ليس هناك قرار اصعب ولكن احيانا في
بعض الاوضاع هذا امر ضروري كما قلت امس
على تويتر في تغيير سابقى سفيرا في
السودان وسوف اعمل لمن هم في السودان وسوف
اعود حين تتيح لي الظروف ذلك ولكن اعتقد
انه ساكون اكثر افاده حنا اكون خارج
السودان بالنظر الى ظروف او عفوا صعوبه
الظروف حيث بد ات تنفذ منا كل الامدادات
وحتى الاتصالات بدات
تنقطع ووجب عليها فقط الاعتماد على هاتف
طريقه فعاله للعمل السفيرا
على الازمه برمتها في السودان بعد خروج
اغلب البعثات الدبلوماسيه وتعليق عمل
السفارات
الاساسيه هي
قله وجود الاشخاص الذين يمكنن الاعتماد
عليهم من اطراف ثالثه وليس من طرفي النزاع
للحصول على معلومات نحن كنا نعمل على مدار
الساعه منذ فتره طويله لكي نتوصل الى ويتم
التوصل الى اتفاق سياسي لانهاء هذا الوضع
ليعيد السودان الى المسار الانتقالي وصولا
الانتخابات قريبا ان جزءا من هذا العمل قد
يبدو اسهل من الخارج ولكن جزءا اخر من
العمل يتطلبوا منا ان نتواجد على الارض او
ان نتواصل باستمرار مع طرفي النزاع ولكن
البعض لا يريدون الاصغاء لا يريدون وقف
القتال ولا يريدون ان نكون موجودين من اجل
وقف القتال
اذا لا يريدوننا ان نكون موجودين لكي
نساعد في تامين الممرات الانسانيه او
ايصال مساعدات الانسانيه هناك تركيز اكبر
على دور الاسره الدوليه حاليا وانا اتفهم
ذلك ولكن انا لا يمكن ان اتحدث فقط عن
الدول الغربيه ايضا يمكن ان نتحدث عن دول
اقليميه دول تتشارك حدودا مع السودان كلنا
يجب ان نفكر بطريقه نفسها وان ندعو الى
وقف القتال والى ارساء الاستقرار قدره
الامكان بما يتيح ايصال مساعدات الانسانيه
ومن ثم تبدا العمليه السياسيه قدر الامكان
اذا فهمتك بشكل دقيق السفير اندرو كول قلت
بان هناك جهات لم تريد بان تكونوا موجودين
على الارض يعني هل نفهم بانه طلب منكم
مغادره الخرطوم هناك اطراف داخليه في
السودان طلبت منكم اخلاء البعثه
الدبلوماسيه النرويجيه من الخرطوم صحح لي
لو سمحت
لما نطلب منا احد ان نغادر هذا كان قرارا
انا اتخذته مع وزاره طبعا ولكن انا قرانا
الوضع قرانا بعد تطورات وكان واضحا
بالنسبه الي انه علي المغادره طيب علمنا
بانه بالساعات الاولى للاشتباكات بعثات
دبلوماسيه حاولت ان تتواصل مع اطراف
النزاع لوقف اطلاق النار بماذا اصطدمت هذه
الجهود السفيرانجو
ساتحدث عن العراقيل الاساسيه هنا
الاطراف التي وافقت على وقف اطلاق النار
دائما قالت اذا تعرض الاعتداء لدينا الحق
في دفاع النفس نحن لا نعرف من يعتدي على
من ولكن اعتقد بصوره عامه
امكن ان يكون هناك التزام اكبر لاحترام
وقفه الاقنار وتوصل الى ترتيبات تتيح
ايصال مساعدات الانسانيه فتح ممرات
انسانيه امنه وتطبيق وقف اطلاق النار لقد
كان هناك نداء باتجاه ذلك ولكن هذا لم
يحترم استمر القصف استمر القيطان ولم ينفذ
وقت اطلاق النار ليس صعبا على الاطراف ان
تنفذه اذا فعلا اراد ذلك انت لست بحاجه
الى الرد اذا تعرضت للاعتداء اذا اردت
فعلا ان تحترم وقفا وقفه اطلاق النا هذا
لم يحصل هذا لم يحصل نحن في تواصل مع
فرنسا والولايات المتحده وهم يتواصلون مع
الجنرلين الكل لا يدخر وسعا ونحن كلنا
نبذل كل الجهود لكي يتوقف القطار سوف
يتوقف طبعا في النهايه ولكن كلما كان ذلك
ابكر كان ذلك افضل شكرا لك على هذه
المداخله وانت في مطار ما سفير النرويج في
السودان اندرو استنسن وانت في طريقك الى
اوسلو بعد عمليه اجلاء لبعثتكم في السودان
شكرا لك